As long as there are those that remember what
was there will always be those that will resist
you took everything from me i don't
even know who you are you will
humans are odd they think order
and chaos are somehow opposites and
try to control what won't be but a
thing isn't beautiful because it lasts
vision what do you want for
people to see you as i do
tell me what you feel
I just feel you
Happy New Year everyone Welcome
back this is going to be my marvel legends episode1
video for Wandavision i'll explain what's going
on and how this all ties in and what they're
doing with the extra content for the Wandavision
episodes and i will be doing videos for all the
Wandavision episodes starting next week as well
so be sure to subscribe if you're brand new to my
channel we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just leave all your predictions
for x-men stuff during the Wandavision series so
if you have no idea what's going on with this
they just dropped a trailer they didn't really
promote this during the big disney plus investor
meeting with the loki trailer and all the other
big trailers and teasers they released like thor
4 love and thunder the fantastic four movie they
just announced there were so many things that they
announced at that disney plus investor meeting no
surprise that they left some of it on the floor
but the way they're treating this is sort of like
bonus content for the shows that they're billing
as its own show so marvel legends is like its own
show on disney plus but they're doing episodes
like this for all the different marvel phase 4
projects they didn't say if they're doing it for
all the movies like if they'll drop a black widow
episode before the black widow movie comes out in
may but it sounds like they're at least doing it
for the disney plus series so when they get ready
to release the falcon and winter soldier episodes
in march they'll drop marvel legends episodes for
both falcon and winter soldier same thing for loki
but had the virus not delayed everything i have
a feeling they probably would have turned this
into a bigger show with more narration and footage
from the actors talking about their characters but
the other new shows that marvel's doing for the
marvel phase 4 projects that they didn't announce
at the disney plus investor meeting include disney
gallery episodes for all the marvel series just
like they did for the mandalorian season 1 and
season 2. those are the episodes where they do a
much bigger version of what you probably thought
that this marvel legends series was going to be
because all these marvel phase 4 series are
basically like a 150 million dollar movie just
turned into a tv series with six to
nine or ten episodes just depending
because the other big surprise is that Wandavision
is going to have nine episodes total even though
they're dropping the first two together next
week i'll explain what's going on with that too
paul bettany claims that there are more
visual effects shots in Wandavision than
in all of avengers end game which sounds
like a bit of a surprise in that the whole
decades of sitcom thing obviously that we've
seen in all the trailers in the episodes
only lasts for a little while before the show
actually turns into a much bigger traditional
avengers storyline so for those of you that aren't
big fans of sitcoms in general or you just don't
follow the logic with what they're doing with
some of these episodes in the meta easter eggs
the show will turn into more of a traditional big
marvel production that you would expect from one
of the marvel movies by the end of the series the
whole thing with them blowing through the decades
of sitcoms is mostly just a deal with the house
of m easter eggs mutants coming into the mcu in a
big way the x-men characters and her twin children
billy and tommy that you actually see during the
trailers it's only one of the ways that they're
bringing x-men into the mcu now that they have
control of those characters but because they want
to have their cake and eat it too so to speak they
want to do the storyline where they give birth to
their children like they actually have that family
but they also want to have those kids be adults
so they can actually do really cool avengers
level stuff they have to age them up so that's why
they're aging through the decades of television
like as you go through the different decades
the kids get bigger and bigger and bigger until
the end of the series when they'll probably be
teenagers that's also part of the reason why i
think they're releasing the first two episodes at
the same time next week instead of waiting another
week to drop episode two just to burn through the
black and white era of television faster so people
don't get super confused with the whole sitcom
trope like why is it like this it feels kind of
weird like if you've never watched nick at night
or you never watch i love lucy or any of those
classic tv shows you'd probably be pretty confused
if you walked into this cold the other cool house
of m thing that was going on recently elizabeth
olsen was just talking about that storyline in
her own words she implied that when she was first
cast as scarlet witch for avengers age of ultron
that was one of the comics that they gave her to
check out and it became one of her favorites like
she had really wanted to do that story line for a
long time but never thought that they would ever
be able to do it just because of the whole right
situation with the x-men being at fox i've always
been hungry to lean into the comic book stories
that we're leaning into in this show and i didn't
know if i'd have the opportunity to explore it
which is the reason why i wanted to be a part of
the avengers to begin with when joss
asked me to he said look at these comics
and tell me if you are interested and those
specific comics are the ones that feige said
this is what our show is going to be about for
Wandavision the whole theory about why they're
doing mcu house of m through Wandavision is like i
said incorporating the x-men into the mcu heading
into marvel phase four marvel phase five before
they actually do their full-blown rebooted mcu
x-men film obviously they announced the fantastic
four film is coming first i think the reason for
that is just to give an extra cooling off period
because it's so soon after the fox x-men movies
in dark phoenix just went down so bad for so many
people so most of those characters are gonna be
recast eventually and fantastic four unlike the
x-men movies has never really had a solid movie
before so they have much more need for a desperate
really big splashy reboot in a solid film
finally i'm sure chris evans is going to be
posting all kinds of memes when they eventually
release that fantastic four film the really cool
thing about scarlet witch that a lot of you will
know if you've been following a lot of the extra
mcu stuff the tie-in material is that a long time
ago they actually confirmed that the mind stone
didn't give her her powers it merely unlocked
powers that were already there so that was them
just laying the seeds for them to reveal that
she's been a mutant this whole time they've been
doing that since the marvel phase one movies kevin
feige and the marvel people just sort of riding
in x-men easter eggs and mutant easter eggs in
the background so that when eventually they did
work up to a big crossover with x-men characters
they could say they've been here this whole
time see we've been planning it this whole time
there's even the iron man movie post
credit scene that got deleted early on
where nick fury directly references mutants that's
how early goes back to the very first mcu film
as if gamma accidents radioactive bug
bites and assorted mutants weren't enough
i have to deal with a spoiled brat who doesn't
play well with others and wants to keep all his
toys to himself you notice that he also mentioned
spider-man during that so you have to keep in mind
that that was happening before they had rebooted
with the andrew garfield amazing spider-man
franchise way before tom holland so at the time
the spider-man that he was speaking of in that
reference was the tobey maguire spider-man and
it sounds like if all this crossover spider-verse
stuff works out for spider-man 3 they're
actually going to be able to pay that off finally
the other big way they're incorporating the x-men
characters into the mcu going forward is just
straight-up multiverse alternate universes
explainer like literally characters legacy actors
who still play their characters from the fox x-men
films crossing over into future marvel movies so
like if james mcavoy or michael fassbender want a
cameo they can actually do that and just say they
came from an alternate reality pretty straight up
easy explainer the whole thing with Wandavision
though is that is them taking her full comic
book x-men scarlet witch where she can legit warp
reality around her it's sort of the mcu version of
her chaos magic where hopefully they build up to a
situation at the end of the series where she wants
to keep her children she doesn't want to let go
of them because she created them in this alternate
reality where she tries to merge that fake reality
or aspects of it with the main mcu reality that's
really where you have big doctor strange two stuff
getting involved because you have blending
of alternate realities and as he said dr
strange's number one priority is protecting the
fidelity of our reality the main mcu reality
that's why during the Wandavision series just like
the history of the scarlet witch character in the
comics she's been both a villain and both an ally
to the avengers she's normally viewed as a good
character so she's not really a villain in the
traditional sense more of an antagonist at times
they're doing that with the scarlet witch
character during the Wandavision series where
she winds up causing a lot of the problems
that they do have to solve during the series
my episode videos will post every friday
it'll be the same schedule as the mandalorian
i'm still working on a new loki series video
they just made a couple really big really cool
announcements about what's going on with the
future of that series and obviously that's
going to be crossing over with thor for love
and thunder so while you wait for that click
here for that brand new teaser that they
released for thor 4 love and thunder and
learn about christian bale's character and click
here for that big scene from Wandavision episode
1 that they just released thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!